antibiotika gehören wohl zu den größten
und bedeutendsten erfindungen der
medizingeschichte
doch es gibt immer mehr bakterien die
gegen diese medikamente immun sind die
folgen sind tödlich diese übermächtigen
bazillen sind eine große gefahr für uns
alle war jetzt ein renommierter
mikrobiologe es gibt schätzungen nach
denen schon bald mehr menschen durch
solche erreger sterben werden als durch
krebs ob uns wirklich eine kein
apokalypse droht und warum resistente
bakterien nicht nur für die betroffenen
selbst sondern auch für unsere gesamte
gesellschaft zu einer katastrophe führen
könnten jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
so klein die erreger auch sind ihr
schaden ist enorm besonders besorgt sind
experten und expertinnen im
medizinischen bereich über die
krankheitserreger die sich nicht mehr
mit antibiotika behandeln lassen und
tatsächlich haben die infektionen mit
bazillen die eine resistenz gegen
antibiotika entwickelt haben den letzten
jahren enorm zugenommen gängige
antibiotika versagen und ärzte und
ärztin wissen nicht mehr wie sie kranken
helfen können sie sterben der worst case
das ist tatsächlich so weit kommen
konnte
das hätte man so jahrelang nicht
vermutet antibiotika galten als
allheilmittel die bakterielle
erkrankungen wirkungsvoll und vor allem
dauerhaft bekämpfen können übersehen hat
man dabei dass bakterien wahre
überlebenskünstler sind wir haben hier
schon öfter darüber berichtet das fatale
daran dass bakterien immer öfter eine
resistenz gegen antibiotika entwickeln
und das war eigentlich abzusehen denn
das volk ganz den mechanismen der
evolution diejenigen organismen die sich
ihrer umwelt am besten anpassen
überleben und können sich vermehren und
so werden eben auch resistenzen
entwickelt durch zufällige veränderungen
in ihrem erbgut kam es also dass
vereinzelte bakterien weniger
empfindlich auf das angewandte
antibiotikum reagiert haben sie
überlebten die behandlung mit diesem
antibiotikum diese bakterien konnten
sich dann vermehren haben so ihre
unempfindlichkeit an die nächste
bakterien generation weitergegeben hat
zudem in die karten gespielt
das in den letzten jahren immer häufiger
antibiotika eingesetzt wurden sowohl bei
uns menschen und auch bei den tieren der
verschwenderische einsatz von
antibiotika in der massentierhaltung ist
längst bekannt zudem war oft auch die
anwendung fehlerhaft beispielsweise eine
zu kurze einnahmedauer das ist ein grund
dass ich tatsächlich bakterien so
verändern können dass sie fast gegen
alle gängigen antibiotika resistent
geworden sind sie überlebten die
behandlung weil sie nicht ausreichend
lang war und so lernten sie das
betreffende antibiotikum kennen und
konnten sich anpassen und wenn das für
alle antibiotika gilt dann nennt man das
multi resistenz und dieses ergebnis ist
eine riesige katastrophe für uns alle
das hat jetzt auch der renommierte
mikrobiologe thema walsh von der
university cardiff eindringlich auf den
punkt gebracht bei der vor dem box
konferenz in berlin
der in seinem vortrag vor den folgen von
antibiotikaresistenzen gebrannt er
bezeichnet sie als ein großes
medizinisches und soziales problem das
auch für die wirtschaft und den
wohlstand unserer gesellschaft böse
enden kann
zitat dagegen ist der dreck sind ein
tropfen im pazifik so what er macht
dafür auch die dummheit der menschen
verantwortlich und meint damit konkret
hygienemängel schmutziges trinkwasser
und korruption
der mikrobiologe forscht seit jahren zu
diesem thema 2011 hatte er
beispielsweise herausgefunden dass in
indien bakterien mit dem gen ndm-1 sehr
verbreitet sind oft auch als super
bakterium bezeichnet denn sie sind
resistent gegen eine bestimmte form von
antibiotika beta laktamase die
konsequenzen der indischen regierung
waren lächerlich sie ließen den
mikrobiologen also wollte ein jahr lang
nicht mehr in irland ein weiteres
vorgehen um die resistenzen zu bekämpfen
das blieb aus anders dagegen die
reaktion der chinesischen und
thailändischen regierung als volt
enthüllte dass viele bakterien dort das
gehen ncr 1 tragen dieses gen macht
bakterien gegen das antibiotikum
colistin stark fatal wenn man bedenkt
dass kristin oft als letztes mittel
gegen resistente keime eingesetzt wird
thailand china stoppten den einsatz von
christin als wachstumsbeschleuniger in
der tiermast eine wichtige und wirklich
alternativlose reaktion denn studien
zufolge sterben jährlich schon jetzt
weltweit 700.000 menschen an infektionen
durch medikamenten resistente keime bis
2050 könnte diese zahl auf 10 millionen
opfer steigen dies sind die hochrechnung
einer britischen expertengruppe im
auftrag der britischen regierung und das
hieße dann mehr tote durch resistente
erreger als durch krebserkrankungen eine
wirklich bedenkliche entwicklung finde
ich zu ihr ich euch hier natürlich auf
dem laufenden halten wollte kein video
dazu verpassen drückt mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen und vergesslich den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter und dafür kräftig mit bakterien
als datenspeicher auch sehr spannend und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran
genau